We will now go through a
probability calculation for
the case where we have a
continuous sample space.
We revisit our earlier example
in which we were throwing a
dart into a square target,
the square target
being the unit square.
And we were guaranteed that our
dart would fall somewhere
inside this set.
So our sample space is the
unit square itself.
We have a description of the
sample space, but we do not
yet have a probability law.
We need to specify one.
The choice of a probability
law could be arbitrary.
It's up to us to choose how to
model a certain situation.
And to keep things simple, we're
going to assume that our
probability law is a uniform
one, which means that the
probability of any particular
subset of the sample space is
going to be the area
of that subset.
So if we have some subset lying
somewhere here and we
ask what is the probability that
we fall into that subset?
The probability is exactly
the area of
that particular subset.
Once more, this is an arbitrary
choice of a
probability law.
There's nothing in our
assumptions so far that would
force us to make this
particular choice.
And we just use it for the
purposes of this example.
So now let us calculate
some probabilities.
Let us look at this event.
This is the event that the sum
of the two numbers that we get
in our experiment is less
than or equal to 1/2.
It is always useful to work in
terms of a picture and to
depict that event in a picture
of the sample space.
So in terms of that sample
space, the points that make
this event to be true are just a
triangle that lies below the
line, where this is the line,
that's x plus y equals 1/2.
Anything below that line, these
are the outcomes that
make this event happen.
So we're trying to find the
probability of this red event.
We have assumed that probability
is equal to area.
Therefore, the probability we're
trying to calculate is
the area of a triangle.
And the area of a triangle is
1/2 times the base of the
triangle, which is 1/2 in our
case, times the height of the
triangle, which is again
1/2 in our case.
And the end result is 1/8.
Let us now calculate another
probability.
Now, this is an event
that consists of
only a single element.
We take the point 0.5, 0.3,
which sits somewhere here.
The event of interest is a set,
but that set consists of
a single point.
So we're asking for the
probability that our dart
falls exactly on top
of that point.
What is it?
Well, it is the area
of a set that
consists of a single point.
What is the area of
a single point?
It is 0.
And similarly for any other
single point inside that
sample space that we might have
considered, the answer is
going to be 0.
Let us now abstract from this
example, as well as the
previous one, and note
the following.
Probability calculations
involve a
sequence of four steps.
Starting with a word description
of a problem, of a
probabilistic experiment,
we first write
down the sample space.
Then we specify a
probability law.
Let me emphasize again here
that this step has some
arbitrariness in it.
You can choose any probability
law you like, although for
your results to be useful
it would be good if your
probability law captures the
real-world phenomenon you're
trying to model.
Typically you're interested in
calculating the probability of
some event.
That event may be described in
some loose manner, so you need
to describe it mathematically.
And if possible, it's always
good to describe it in terms
of a picture.
Pictures are immensely
useful when going
through this process.
And finally, the last step is to
go ahead and calculate the
probability of the event
of interest.
Now, a probability law in
principle specifies the
probability of every
event, and there's
nothing else to do.
But quite often the probability
law will be given
in some implicit manner, for
example, by specifying the
probabilities of only
some of the events.
In that case, you may have to
do some additional work to
find the probability of
the particular event
that you care about.
This last step sometimes
will be easy.
Sometimes it may
be complicated.
But in either case, by following
this four-step
procedure and by being
systematic you will always be
able to come up with a single
correct answer.